[Music]
there are about 150 urban mega
developments branded as new cities
underway and they're located in over 40
countries around the world and that's
not including china where there are at
least 500 new cities being built from
scratch
we're in the age of new cities right now
this is one of them songdo in south
korea
looking at the city today you could
almost forget that two decades ago it
was just an idea
we used to just joke around
that's the combination of word
and siberia
the master plan starts
with a blank page
there's not a line for a road there's no
dot for a subway stop in this particular
case after all it was landfill so
you're literally starting
tabula rasa
before there is even any terra firma
as the urban population grows so does
our need for new cities and there are
hopes that songdo could be a blueprint
for other developments around the world
but the design and construction of this
40 billion smart city hasn't been
universally well received
it's not the nicest place on earth
but it's definitely one of the best
examples of new cities developed in the
last 20 years that actually have people
living in here that haven't been pushed
or forced to live here
we call it tomorrowland
both to kind of reference this idea that
it feels a little disney-ish and very
manicured but also the joke that like
it'll be better tomorrow
new cities have generally always been
built by governments or kingdoms they
have been built since antiquity but
there are moments of intensification
so during the colonial era we were
seeing dozens and dozens of new cities
being built in the colonies
and then in cities of the 1950s 1960s
like chandigarh and brasilia were built
as nation building projects these are
cities that were experimental they were
using a new type of aesthetic a new type
of architecture to represent a country
that wanted to take a totally new
direction
and now since the last 20 25 years new
cities are seen as being profit-making
machines basically
some of these are even private gated
cities
it's almost like a gigantic mall except
it's the size of a city
there are other private cities that are
listed on stock exchanges and they're
answerable to shareholders
and so a tremendous amount is being
invested in these projects in the hopes
that they'll attract foreign direct
investment and sort of spark a new type
of digital economy
one of the most expensive examples of
this idea is songdo international
business district
the city is built on reclaimed land in
the yellow sea just a two-hour flight
from major destinations in asia
the land reclamation began in the
mid-1990s and songdo became an extension
of incheon a neighbouring city whose
government set up the incheon free
economic zone to facilitate free trade
between south korea and the rest of the
world including china which at that
point wasn't a part of the world trade
organization
so i think they might have purposely not
to make you feel like it's a korean city
the incheon government contracted kpf a
new york-based architecture firm to
design songdo's master plan
lead designer james von klemperer and
over 60 architects spent eight years
completing the project
there were hundreds of consultants of
engineers
designers forecasters
material science people
so overall you probably had i would say
up to a thousand
different designers and consultants
working on this city at one time
[Music]
we don't make a city without any kind of
templates and any kind of precedence
that inform us about urban life as they
say we stand on the shoulders of others
and rather than trying to start with
some new theory about human interaction
and
building density and form and urban
patterns we borrowed in a way
uh pieces of solutions from other cities
so we sort of pulled and pushed and like
like an artist making a collage with
different preset elements
try to use these pieces of cities
as inspirations and borrow from some of
their dimensioning systems and
strategies
these ideas were all woven into songdo's
urban fabric the physical structure of
every city that defines its character
things like building types open spaces
roads and lighting
the team created neighborhoods using a
pattern of streets
local stores
and a mix of low-rise buildings and
towers
all centred around a school and parks
[Music]
when it comes to the urban fabric of
sundo we have a relatively large city
block and large avenues and a lot of
really big scale green areas and open
spaces
alberto gonzalez is an architect and
urban planner and has been living in
songdo since 2017
one of the nice things about sunder
urban design is that the blocks are very
open so you can actually walk through
all the blocks many of them have outdoor
gyms others have playgrounds for kids so
it's literally open for anyone who wants
to go in
and that's a kind of a key distinction
if you compare to other
asian cities in which you typically have
gated communities
so yeah here is uh one of the small
pocket parks and um even though you are
not too far from one of the main avenues
you feel like uh in a more protected
side i think it really makes a city a
bit more vibrant
one of the tenets
that we accepted or embraced in in new
songdo city plan was to make it a
pedestrian city
a place where you'd be comfortable
walking from district to district or
within districts but korean planning and
korean practice of building had embraced
the automobile those who were working
with us from
government ministries said you must have
an eight-lane road at the edge of this
part of town
or even going through the middle of a
neighborhood we said well
that doesn't sound very
attractive
kpf couldn't stop the highways being
built so instead they focused on how
they were designed
zoning restrictions in korea mean that
buildings along these large avenues are
usually set back from the street to
protect residents from noise and
pollution
but the large sidewalks created as a
result often lack character like
textures on the facades or shops and
cafes that make streets interesting for
people to use
and so we had to in essence
break or change the korean code to be
able to have uh architectural textures
and buildings right on the street
it would have been very difficult to do
with a small one-off design but the kind
of
scale of this project warranted that
everybody stepped back and think again
about what made
uh the best kind of rules for building
a
transportation will get better but until
then i'm going to use my car
some elements of songdo's design like
reducing car use may not be fully
realized yet but with forty percent of
the city left to be built there's a call
out for initiatives from the public on
how to improve it
alberto is consulting on one of those
projects
we are exploring uh ways in which we can
bring the space back to the people
reduce the usage of cars
so this is one of the spots that people
criticize a lot and of course with a lot
of reasons we have like a total of ten
lanes five on each side plus the buffer
area i mean we literally have a huge
avenue it's almost like a highway type
of scale so the idea is that in this
central section there's enough room to
put in a light rail here like a tram and
maybe you know one or two lanes that
both sides can get reduced and can be
occupied with sitting areas with pop-up
kiosks
so by getting rid of certain areas that
are now purely used by cars
we can actually increase the chances for
you know randomness to happen so uh this
type of urban randomness is actually
what makes city life much more
interesting
technology was another key element in
songdo's initial design and it became
one of the first smart city projects in
the world
i see a lot of cctv if you go
out on the street you don't see any
power poles or wires they're all
underground
cisco committed to spending 47 million
to provide the city with smart
infrastructure
we designed systems
that would ensure
a highly efficient use of energy and
other resources of water even the use of
waste so this is the sort of thing you
can do when you design a city from
scratch
because those infrastructural systems
are not there
this is songdo's operation center which
manages all the infrastructure as well
as monitors over 5000 sensors and
cameras spread around the city
foreign
a lot of these new city projects brand
themselves as smart
they are trying to be the silicon valley
of southeast asia or the silicon valley
of latin america
or the silicon valley of africa etc
they seem to be inspired by this sort of
entrepreneurial stance of taking big
risks moving fast and breaking things
but it's not just their money that
they're risking they're risking land
they're risking the lives of residents
who relocate to these places
the risk of failure is high with some
new cities turning into expensive ghost
towns that aren't designed to cater to
the needs of locals
oftentimes locals are priced out of
these new cities because the new cities
are not built for them they're built for
investors so we're seeing uh cities that
are only 10
20 occupied the units are all sold
there's just nobody living in them
there are a lot of ghost cities in china
that have been filled in there are other
ghost cities that are still very
under-occupied
but whether these new cities get built
or not whether they happen or not
whether they fill in or not people are
still going to make money
songdo seems to be defying this ghost
city trend its population is tracking
its development now at about 60 percent
of the original target of 300 000 and
there's an appetite to replicate its
success
the development has been described as an
example of a city in a box with
ready-made and tested solutions that can
be quickly applied elsewhere
the same developer and architects were
contracted to design a new city in china
called mei shi lake its detailed master
plan took two and a half years while
songdoze took four
no city should ever
be a copy of another city
because uh
the the particular needs of place and
time are so different
but
there are some techniques in city
building that have been taken from one
city to another quite successfully
and you could see if somebody needs to
build very quickly
they might want to understand some
templates
of techniques that have been used before
i think a song though is a successful
story it's definitely something that is
going to be a work in progress
and the typical question is can we
replicate this
can this city in a box type of
environment be literally transferred to
other areas
i think there's so many ingredients that
came
into the
mix
for songdo to happen that i certainly
think that it's
not easy to replicate
this sort of notion that we can build
something
that other people will want to emulate
and
will be the first will be a model for
other people to copy that's a really
appealing
aspect of a lot of these new cities
cities evolve over the centuries and
over the millennia into
you know cities that we know today
beijing or delhi or other major
historical cities
and so given time maybe any new city can
fill in and evolve and become something
lively and successful
[Music]
you